qu'à l'école et quelle éducation pour
demain vaste question posée par la
mairie des clayes-sous-bois lors des
premières assises de l'éducation pour en
débattre enseignants éducateurs
directeur d'école mais aussi quelques
parents s'étaient réunis à l'espace
philippe noiret en expert jean claude
guérin ancien inspecteur de l'éducation
nationale animait le débat c'était une
volonté justement de vouloir rôdeur de
réunir tous les partenaires non
seulement l'éducation les partenaires de
l'éducation nationale mais tout ce tous
les partenaires qui gravitent autour de
l'enfant pour justement prendre l'enfant
dans sa globalité et ne vais pas divisé
en sections les différents moments d'un
enfant par exemple au cours d'une
journée de la petite enfance à l'école
en passant par les loisirs sportifs et
culturels
il s'agissait pour les débatteurs de
prendre en compte chaque moment de la
journée de l'enfant la ville des clés
fut déjà précurseur dans l'aménagement
du temps de l'enfant à l'école victor
hugo afin d'apporter un autre regard de
l'enfant sur l'école la ville avait
proposé après la pause déjeuner un temps
loisirs sport culture et théâtre avec
différents intervenants ces premières
assises était l'occasion d'une autre
réflexion il faut l'implication des
parents 7 ans parce que l'esprit cole
sont là parce que s'il n'y a pas si on
laisse
que dans l'école faire le travail des
parents ça va pas les dents creuses pour
cordes le sauvage l'école d'aujourd'hui
déjà très bien a bien organisé on peut
l'améliorer c'est clair
il n'y a pas que l'école à améliorer il
gère tout le tout l'environnement et les
parents en particulier on peut
l'impliquer dans l'école mais on peut
aussi
exiger d'eux qu'ils aient aussi les
mêmes
objectifs que l'école le matin on a
parlé de manière très très gêné râble
delà de l'enfant dans sa globalité on
trouvait là la position de chacun la
position bas de l'éducation nationale
des enseignants mais aussi le rôle
qu'ils ont des parents et puis au delà
de de tous les intervenants qui
viendront pour pour se compléter un
débat très philosophique de prochaines
assises ne sont pas prévues pour
l'instant